[Music]
welcome to
the what podcast just days away from
glory glory glory hallelujah i can't
believe it's actually happening can you
believe it's actually happening barry it
still feels as though the rugs could get
pulled out from there
right
yeah
it isn't that terrible to feel that way
but yeah
no i it's happening i'm already starting
to get i told you last time starting to
get the night sweats
starting to worry about camping starting
yeah oh i do it every year what are the
night sweats for
i i told you i just start thinking about
all that walk in that camping you know i
don't camp like taco every week this is
a this is a new thing for me
yeah taco you literally do this every
week this has become like you went to
bonnaroo once and then bought a bus and
then you've been camping ever since
well it's backwards because i bought the
bus first but uh yeah i'm ready i'm
already here in manchester where are you
guys
yeah yeah
see he's by the way i do feel as though
like you know we know barry's gonna just
stay in the basement for the end of time
i don't know where i'm gonna eventually
end up probably new orleans but we all i
think can all
assume that lord taco's final resting
place will be at the manchester walmart
parking lot
there is no place on this planet where
you feel more like yourself is there
no that's correct yeah i can't wait
that's what i'm most excited about
the man literally could live in the
walmart parking lot in manchester for
the rest of time and be totally okay
with it yeah i may never love that
i love that
the rain doesn't bother him the heat
doesn't bothering the crab none of it
bothers him the port-a-potty so prepared
yeah he's used to it
so um one of our former camp mates at
camp nut butter his name is joe he came
up with this really
clever thing that thursday you know my
my thing is always don't go hard on
thursday because you have to set
yourself up for for a marathon here and
you really don't want to wake up friday
not feeling your absolute 100 best
he always said about friday friday was
everybody's best t-shirt day
friday everybody brings out their
absolute best t-shirts so in honor of
best t-shirt friday
i thought that i would show you guys
what would have been my
friday t-shirt
had i be
had i go had i what am i saying if i
were to have gone to bonnaroo this year
but i will bring it out next year when i
come back uh but
here you go here's my big reveal of my
friday
best t-shirt submission all right you
ready
this is a visual by the way so if you're
listening to it i apologize but if
you're watching on youtube get ready for
amanda strip here we go all right
see if you can tell what it is
i'm guessing mr t
[Laughter]
nope not mike tyson
that's nice
mike tyson that is dolly parton
dolly yes i had my dolly parton t-shirt
ready to go for friday
nice nice
and taco's got his uh what podcast
t-shirt is that that was definitely
gonna be this friday is that a friend
that's definitely a friday definitely a
friday this you think this is my best
t-shirt
i've seen what you wear yeah it's the
best t-shirt you got yeah
okay all right yeah you're probably
right all right this will be my friday
the rest of your wardrobe is just pbr
merchandise
it's true
that's true so now i'm gonna have to
rethink my friday t-shirt so nice well
your friday t-shirt has
twinsies
wait a second your friday t-shirt has
always been the same it's that tie-dye
thing that you wear you always go
tie-dye on friday which i always feel as
though the wrong move you should go
tie-dye sunday
sunday is that tie-dye day you know what
i used to be really proud of that and
then i think i saw a reflection in a
window or something and i look like just
that old fat guy in a tie-dye that shows
comic books
[Laughter]
you look like you work at a magic store
i work at a magic store it's not quite
the hip cool look that i thought it was
yeah i saw the grateful dead before they
were the grateful dead they were still
living you know i mean
i'm that guy
they were still the grateful alive you
guys don't know anything i know look at
these kids losers
yeah so i haven't worn it since pretty
much
i don't know at all like i thought i've
seen i you've popped over at my house to
do some you know housework in that shirt
before yeah that's that's because i'm
you know crawling under a basement doing
plumbing work or whatever it is you have
me doing so so i wonder what your best
t-shirt is i don't know i'm gonna have
to figure it out
yeah so i also my other good t-shirt is
uh my uh throwback hill street blues
crew t-shirt that they gave me yeah
that's always a big contender i've seen
it but on saturdays i have to wear the
same shirt because there's a campmate
mike doer with us who is a fellow mets
fan and so every year we have to wear
our mets gear on saturday it's just a
it's just a rule so friday best shirt
saturday mets shirt and then sunday it's
uh just trying to survive the heat nice
i do have a beetle shirt that i'm fond
of that actually was found on the
grounds of bonnaroo
our our campmate
denson found it and gave it to me
you had a shirt on the ground at bonner
i find something you wear
every year oh it's a bit clean i
wouldn't put it on my body
it's been cleaned
oh come on barry yeah yeah
he didn't tell you exactly where he
found it what if he found it what if he
found it in the port-a-potty
[Laughter]
he wrung it out and handed it to you
every year yeah
okay but that is somebody who's already
wearing it yeah when you found it he
just took it off somebody you know i
found this give me that
yeah it doesn't just because you find
something a bonner doesn't mean you
should incorporate it into your life i
mean i've always said like there's
i i always like in those early days it
was such a free-for-all i swear to god
there was that my first year there was a
car on fire
and people were just like man
yeah that's fine
um i was convinced after that first year
that somebody was going to run at me and
throw me a baby
and i would have just been stuck with
this bonnaroo baby walking around and i
guess i guess it's mine now because
that's how
absolute that [ __ ] crazy bonaroo was
those first few years and you know i
don't know if it's still like this but
that um
what did they call what do they call
that row where you walk where you're
walking in where everybody's selling
stuff to you shakedown shakedown street
i don't know if it's as bad as it is
the first year but my god i mean you'd
have a guy selling a dryer door out
there you know shoe strings here the
dollar i mean and they were never part
of the festival they were just you know
hangers on from from manchester and it
was like
i mean
i know what the bonnaroo code is now but
in year two
it did not feel that safe i'll be
totally honest with you it's sort of it
sort of felt like walking to the train
stop here in new york at about three
four o'clock in the morning it was not
sort of where i wanted to be
i guess it was the third or fourth year
i went the big rumor was that they were
gonna that people were gonna be dosing
you they were gonna spray that's right
that's right i did hear that yeah you
were gonna get dosed that's a big thing
and then i do know one year we went um
me and the photographer went out into ga
and they had the like the big yarn
uh art display whatever where people
could rearrange it and
and
this was like two in the afternoon and a
couple of people came up and offered us
pcp and we were like no we're working
and the disappointment on this kid's
face
was unbelievable it wasn't that we
weren't gonna take it he was like
man that would suck if my job prevented
me from
doing this yeah
and we were like have a good time see ya
i don't want i don't want pcp i want pbr
yeah
but i'll just never forget his face he
was like that would be awful
well i mean i i've told this story on
i've told this story on the podcast
before but you know that car that i saw
on fire was was the night that broke me
and i said i'm never coming back to
bonnaroo it was it was right before this
tremendous thunderstorm that just took
over the entire festival and um and it
was the night before it and
i had gotten lost on the way back and
before they didn't have flags they
didn't have like organization to get you
back home you had to go in a direction
and cross your fingers that you were
going in the right way and there weren't
lights you know the only light that you
got was from somebody's car or you know
somebody brought a camp light there was
there's just there was no organization
it was a free-for-all so and hope that
you crawled into the right bluetooth
that's right yeah and so remember you
took you took the wrong turn and because
there was no organization you could be
walking for hours until you realize that
you're going in the wrong direction and
so we took a wrong turn
uh really early on and getting back to
camp and i started looking around i'm
like something just doesn't feel right
there was a car on fire on the right a
double-decker
um
bus thing on the left with a guy peeing
off the top of it onto i think someone's
tent the car on fire was to my right and
then a completely naked girl comes
running up to me grabs me by the neck
and slinkies down my body screaming pcp
[Applause]
crashes down at my foot and i literally
have to kick her off of me
and at that moment me and my buddy dude
we looked at each other like we got to
get the hell out of here we got to get
the hell out of here it was
and then the rain came the next night
and we were like i i we we felt trapped
i've
just never felt so hopeless in my life
and um you know the rain stuck us into
mud like we could not get out that's we
had to pay a kid like 20 40. i can't
remember how much we paid this kid but
it was a lot to pull us out of out of
the mud i mean it was a total
free-for-all and
you know it's kind of it's
it's kind of refreshing to to think
about it that way and see how far it's
come
and you know and the fact that they have
running water now we talk about it all
the time and i know it's nerding out but
man guys like they did not have just the
basic
amenities when we walked in there in
2003 they had none of this stuff
makes you nostalgic for it doesn't it i
mean no it doesn't at all no it doesn't
there's nothing about that that i miss
a lot of people i wonder i wonder where
that uh i wonder where that girl is now
company somewhere i'm sure i'm sure
brian stones dated her uh
so
the other thing too is those first years
like you had to carry
around with you buckets of bug spray
the amount of mosquitoes and bugs was
just
astronomical and what do you see now
not at all
single bug
if you've never been to bonnaroo or if
you haven't thought about this before
just just take in your surroundings you
are in the middle of a field
and you don't see a bug you don't hear a
cricket you uh i mean one year we saw a
raccoon and that's because we're in the
woods behind
the main stage
there's a reason for that
they didn't just magically find the one
field in america that is totally bug
free now they spray this thing down so
heavy duty so that they don't have any
sort of bug problems anymore because
those first few years you i was eaten
alive i think i had
um
i had fire ants in my tent i had
spiders everywhere there were you know
roaches and and oh god mosquito bites
covering me from head to toe
i ever got all that i've seen like two
bugs and that one skunk and that poor
guy woke up in the morning all by
himself and then all of a sudden
80 000 people were
knocking on his door so
but yeah no you and i have commented
many many times whatever they do with
the bugs they got it figured out yeah i
mean there was a time where like uh when
we first started camping
with the first part the first half of
the group before barry got there with
with dents and endure i mean i was
legitimately scared of snakes where we
were camping because
i mean our buddy denson literally found
one one day while he was setting up his
camp he's found a snake and i'm like
this is this doesn't happen anymore and
if you so there's a couple of things
that i have just deathly fears of and
one of them i can't even say it out loud
it panics me so much but when that bug
gets on you and you find it and it
burrows its stupid head into your body
to kill you and give you diseases
those things don't even exist anymore so
you know i think i i think i've found
one of those
in 16 years
youth about ticks or chips
don't say the word oh the trigger
yeah that was a big deal i forgot about
that i forgot about that they had a
whole like tents set up to help get
those things out of people that's right
i forgot that was a big big deal for the
first several years yep those little red
chickens
oh okay alicia said that
uh yeah there you go waxing poetic for
days days gone by taco this is this is
uh you miss all this huh
i know i wish we could go back do you
you really wish you did that's camping
man that's camping getting it
yeah and then like all of these all
these things happen and then you know
this idiot brings like carpet and vacuum
cleaners and you know couches and tents
and people wonder like why would you
ever do this why would you ever right
right there's a reason it's it's it was
hideous
it was unlivable for a while
um
and i wanted to keep coming back so we
had to figure out a way to make this so
much more fun and now
you know they sort of they sort of did
it for you you don't really have to put
forth that much effort anymore
absolutely see look i can be positive
about bonnaroo i'm not always a debbie
downer
yeah you know you got a little you you
got taken to task for our last episode
but you didn't say anything that wasn't
necessarily true hey i think that if if
we weren't fair you would look at us
like we were just total doofus homers
you know every now and then you gotta
you gotta be fair about it and you know
what's fair
um it's not the lineup's not for me this
year it's not the reason why i'm not
going but it's not for me i'll be back
next year and they will they will
probably have a incredible lineup next
year or it's
these things go in cycles
just two years ago we were talking about
the greatest bondaru lineup ever exist
i'm sh they still
have their fastball they'll be fine
and uh you mentioned him a minute ago
but uh you know after we saw all the
comments about last our last show and
and people sort of taking you to task
for being yeah now the one time i saw it
on the reddit i see
you know
the nonsense taco and i came up with a
brilliant solution we went and found the
one person more curmudgeony than you to
be a guest and he couldn't make it this
way so maybe we'll have him on next week
and that's our that's our own brian
stone we were going to have him on oh
yeah dude wait wait till they get a load
of pride to bring things down even
further
that guy hates sunshine babies puppies
yeah
it is incredible and by the way i i kind
of take offense that you would just
describe me as a curmudgeon like brian
stone there is not a thing that we have
in common
that was the point but but go ahead and
tell people why he's not on with us this
morning what is what is so important in
his world
that he couldn't join us to talk about
this your schedule and he will be with
us in camp nut but yeah the man is a
massive atlanta braves fan um
even the braves don't bring him joy like
he still hates the braves even when
they're winning the world series like
this stupid team i hate it thank you
something's gonna go yeah
something's good they're going to take
the ring away
even to this day so he lives in
chattanooga and he could at any moment
take the hour and 15 minute drive down
to
uh whatever the ballpark in atlanta is
called now and
see the world series trophy you know
here in new york i'm a mets fan you can
go to uh you can go to city field to the
mets hall of fame and walk in and see
our two trophies if you really want to
see
history you can walk right there to the
ballpark and see the trophies just like
you can in atlanta how many games does
he go to a year five six seven he could
walk in and see the world series trophy
any day but no he today could not join
us because the world series trophy from
the atlanta braves world series
championship last year has made its trek
to chattanooga and he has got to drive
down and see the world series trophy
he left us
for hardware barry he left us for
hardware
he couldn't go when it was at the
burpees i guess last week
calhoun or whatever
oh the bucky's a [ __ ] driver
i missed it but when it came to
chattanooga i'm not missing that
no i miss it it's been on his calendar
with a big crayon and he will still
[ __ ] about it damn things smaller in
real life yeah it's not as big as i
thought they wouldn't let me touch it
and
i helped earn that thing and i couldn't
touch it
yeah
yeah he'll find some reason to hate it
but yeah that's the reason why he
couldn't uh join us today but you think
he's
speaking of uh best t-shirt you think
he's got his braves world champions
t-shirt on
this guy
um
fashion icon fashion icon brian stone i
mean he doesn't own a shirt that doesn't
have pit stains on it he's never met a
shirt that's clean that he likes i don't
understand it um yeah they all have a
story though man they all haven't seen
him i know because the man he is he has
not seen anything past 1990 that he
likes
yeah yeah i like his uh snaps he's been
sending me he's like got new socks and
they're like up to his knees stripes
right this is what kurt cobain used to
wear
the man's so fashioned forward with
socks but still wears boot cut jeans i
um i don't
get it
uh but because kurt cobain
hey but you're gonna love him when he's
on the show uh well you're gonna
absolutely i love him
can't wait oh barrel alex uh what's
great about uh today is that we get to
go through
the pics from taco and barry and see
what they will be seeing and hopefully
uh give you maybe an outline of some
things that you shouldn't miss as well
on the on the what podcast today barry
and taco's picks next
[Music]
all right guys it's uh it's pick time
this is historically been and taco you
can tell me if i'm right or wrong about
this this has historically been the most
popular episode in
normal what podcast history is whenever
we go through our picks for the festival
why i don't know but uh either way this
is the one that uh
yeah people like more than anything you
know my our most downloaded episode is
what is that
uh i think there was
i know but i think that the reason there
was a large contingent of dashboard moms
that were trying to find you
i really tapped into that demographic
there yeah yeah i bet you did my man he
did yeah
all right so
how do you guys i'm gonna let you
navigate your pics the way that you want
to i usually go day to day but you guys
can do however uh you want yeah we'll go
day to day taco you want to go first
sure you want to do uh back and forth
each day
yeah let's do back and forth so i guess
we'll start with thursday yeah yep um my
my whole festival starts at 4 30 on
thursday with nothing
is that a band that's the band yeah
that's not the job
yep okay writing down nothing all right
yeah okay write that down nothing barry
got it uh
i'm probably gonna go see parrotfish
just because i think the name is funny
and i'm a little bit interested in
sawyer um
what is parrotfish please they're both
from nashville uh it's it kind of starts
both of these sort of start the day a
little bit uh on the folksy
singer-songwritery side
nice way to start and then going very
softly and that into a weather station
so i'll probably be bouncing back and
forth while
taco is over it doing nothing
i'll be doing nothing
what kind of music is nothing by the way
um it's like one of the only like heart
i wouldn't say heavy metal but it's like
a hard rock band it's like one of the
only ones on the lineup so okay
okay it's not the sound of like a bus
engine running
no i would go see that too though
okay
and offered by this lineup it would be a
headliner and talk about what he'd do to
fix it
all right
after nothing
i'm i'm gonna go see blue to tiger
that's her actual name yep yeah and
she's a bass player and some other
songwriter um
pretty good pretty good
is it blue to tiger or blue to t gray
oh that i don't know
yeah it looks like tiger but it could be
uh
barry find out uh
i mean
probably gonna go i'm gonna wait the
i looked at brooke in the bluff a little
bit interesting i'm probably going to go
over the weather the other
yeah and uh recknow and closey and then
griffin all sort of interest me
um
[Music]
so i'm gonna check out
and i don't know how long i'll stay at
all of that but uh i definitely wanna
i definitely plan to check out a whole
lot more edm i think i said this on the
last show than than i probably would
have and that's a pretty good stretch
actually that whole evening is
pretty good
as far as i'm concerned the only thing
i'll say is uh for brook and the bluff
it's a tad early on a thursday for a nap
yeah well it's
it's actually because they are a little
late
i mean after you know sawyer and
parrotfish and so yeah i get in the
weather station too
um okay so what what time are you now up
to when you go to uh
and i know where you're going with this
this is thursday and our rule is don't
go hard on thursday and there's a lot of
you can you can go you can go late on
thursday that's fine just don't go hard
on well
i'm gonna go ahead and jump to it my
find of the festival so far is at 11
o'clock on that tent i think sons of
kenneth if that's the right way to say
it
might be one of my new favorites
absolutely i really like that it's uh
they're london-based it's afrobeats and
jazz um
i like it a lot and i really want to see
them live and and i
that's one i'm going to be putting in
the
rotation here at the house i i
understand but and you're missing the
lead of this band
that you got to see them now because
they're breaking up after this run match
this is their final stretch of shows
that they'll ever do together i did not
know that that's right nice and i i
think half of them were in um the combat
is coming which played i think 2019 so
that's kind of what they do they'll just
like form a little band for a little
while and
and then yeah you gotta see them when
they end and one of them is performing
with uh the smile which is tommy orton
from radiohead mm-hmm okay you guys i
love that band you guys know more than
that's a red zone
that's a really nice project the smile
is everything i've heard so far from
that uh little project is really really
nice yeah you guys know more than me i
just sort of came across them this
morning and uh
i put a big circle around it that's my
that's
to be honest i mean it wasn't until i
mean look this news coming down makes
makes it a whole lot more interesting
and they're probably the show to see on
thursday um and if it was
if it was me giving these pics that i'm
not going to issue any picks since i'm
not making it this year but that would
be the biggest circle circle circle
circle underline underline that i would
be having on thursday because uh
to me it's it's a it's a can't
absolutely cancel that was the one for
me
and uh after that it's probably you know
i'd like to see andy frasco i i feel
like
he and briston maroney which we'll get
to in a bit are sort of
owed some do
you know for what he did uh last year um
and so i'd like to to go and support
um and maybe i will is briston on
thursday no no i said we'll get to him
he's i think he's okay friday um but
he's another one just because he's been
on the show and i really really like him
that i want to make sure to support the
set you know to be there good
yeah yeah and he played uh the other
fest last year
everything got canceled yeah that's what
i mean he's owed a debt for that you
know so so is that rounding out your
entire thursday or do you have more on
thursday to go that's it okay um
i mean i'm looking at side piece on the
schedule what that that's just one of
those names you know
why would i i do i do like i do like
getting into bands where you're just
going for the name it's sort of like uh
like
why would you do that to yourself liking
teams for uniforms
but okay
yeah but yeah that's it
anything else for taco late night on
thursday
no that's pretty much it there's okay
all right if i make it to andy frasco
that's going to be you know like 1 15.
so
is it that late really yeah yeah 15 to 2
15. yeah oh my god okay i'm sorry all
right so um you wake up friday uh is
this the day that they're wow like the
the beer exchanges and the stuff in in
ga is that am i right about that uh yeah
go ahead taco your state will stay in
order
yeah uh friday eleven o'clock to one
o'clock is the beer exchange at pod five
and uh we're gonna be there i think
we're gonna record a show is that right
yes sir
keep the tradition alive i've been
invited to join us
and uh plan to yeah
now is friday going to be the day where
you guys get to drive around on jam
tracks
have we have we settled that are they
going to let us do that is drive around
and and taxi people and jam tracks i
mean hope so we haven't announced that
did we oh yeah did i just break did i
just break things
oh shoot
go ahead let's go ahead
um
does that start yeah well yeah just uh
start with picks uh i'm gonna go i say
isaiah every shot well hang on a second
being the you guys are not big beer
nerds so what are you bringing to the
beer exchange wait what
i
hate to break
the news but neither one of you
i don't take as
as craft beer nerds so what are you
bringing to exchange
oh i got something good to bring i know
it's an award winner i got it yeah i got
it
this is an award-winning highlighter i
know
yeah i know it's never never not great
right
the point the point for it's so
hysterical for for
for taco he will legitimately bring pbr
and trade with someone
for a pbr
you will literally just swap pvr go to
whoever else is there and feel real real
good about it yeah
got it got to try a west coast pbr man
that's where it's at
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm dying for it iowa city pbr yes he's
looking at the made on date he's
studying the maid on day
barry barry what are you bringing
exactly i may be a hutton and smith
because it's local it's one of my
favorites so i haven't i haven't thought
about what i'm bringing yet i know i'm
going
um
well a couple of years ago the uh
wonderful people at
what is the name of that brewery taco on
main street pontoon brewing no no no the
one in chattanooga on main street what
is this oh and chattanooga yeah what is
that thing called
oh
the wonderful people at odd story had uh
given us all of these beers to uh take
to the craft beer
exchange and that was very very nice of
them uh you should oh that's right yeah
they they gave us some very highly uh
specialized unreleased stuff that we
shared and i don't know they should you
should reach back out to them and get
some of their stuff yeah
we'll talk to them i'm sure there's
somebody local who'd love to be part of
it maybe several absolutely that's a
great idea
so yeah we're going to do that um
you know when we talked about this
lineup before i
i talked about friday being pretty heavy
but the more i studied it today man
that's that's it's it's a good one i
wish some of these were more spread out
than they are
thursday to me yeah i i actually agree i
think friday i'm sorry friday is is my
favorite day of the of the festival yeah
it's it's pretty much
if not all day most of the day for sure
i mean by the way what's the uh have you
guys looked at the long range forecast
what does the weather so far look like
is it even does it even matter yet i
think good right
it looks good okay yeah all right i mean
you could just you could almost just go
to that tent all day long and stay and
be relatively happy
so you're gonna do beer exchange until
one
which will mean which will actually be 2
30. uh
you'll get back to camp and then do what
three o'clock what's barry doing well 2
15. maggie rose three o'clock is briston
and you're not getting you're not
getting there by 2 15. i i promise you
you just it's not happening well i know
um so three should be your target and
see bristol maroon
and i agree i think this kid has got
something i i
there's something about him that is he's
a really good songwriter he's clever
he's got a great voice he's local um
he just needs that moment and i feel
like he's on the cusp of it right i feel
like this kid's on the cusp of breaking
out i agree
yeah i meant to write them down yeah
bristol moroni he was on the show by the
way
go back and listen to the interview yeah
that's a great interview good kid that's
why we i discovered him
that's
that's how i discovered i mean i didn't
oh okay
all right i know that sounded wrong
whiskey myers i saw last month here in
town they're right after him
you know but that's uh sort of leads
into isaiah rashad which uh taco
mentioned uh and the regrets
uh definitely gonna go see isaiah just
because he's from i know see what's what
i'm saying once you start looking at it
yeah robert plant i'm getting ahead of
myself but uh
yeah it that what time what time is
plant 6 45
oh yeah uh interesting across from
japanese breakfast at 6 30.
right
so
i will
look
i know
i have i have i love japanese breakfast
so much but boy that last bonaroo show
put such
a bad taste in my mouth i don't know um
i've i i told their manager that and i
promised that i'd give it another shot
because i love her so much and i love
that band so much so if it was me i
would put all of those
bad feelings aside and come back and
give it one more shot because
it just it it's got to be better than
that there's no way it could be that
again i don't uh it is yeah they were at
um shakiness yeah how was it
yeah it was good the problem was they
were up against um king gizzard
and so you've got two completely
different sounds and you know i was
trying to go back and forth and i was
like no i just i just got to stay with
the king do you think it's late night it
was did it get like overpowered
i mean
was it was it a sound
no it was just it was just two different
flavors you know okay
it was more of a scheduling conflict
thing not like a sound battle yeah
i i think japanese breakfast should have
been more early afternoon
yeah see and what time are they what
time are they on friday by the way barry
6 30
and uh
my my next spot you know robert plant
that's good yeah i put him up there and
you know he's a former led zeppelin he's
you know you you see a beetle when you
can see a beetle you see a
zeppelin guy when you can see and
allison krause obviously has the voice
of
i have taken robert plant totally for
granted every time he's on a schedule
every time he comes to town i'm just
like
no i'll see it sometime and you're
speaking to led zeppelin yeah yeah there
was an article that they have kicked off
this tour and they've been covering some
led zeppelin songs yeah yeah that i
can't remember what they do but yeah um
that she i think she brought to the
table so
alison cross right allison krause and
that yep i mean she's one of the great
voices in all of the world
so that
uh and you know 6 45 there on the what
stage
um crowd's going to be as we've said
before not huge so you'll be able to
to get up close no matter what so that's
a tough call right there
and japanese breakfast is at that
yes
okay yeah i mean that's the same stage
that she was at um a couple years ago
but it was much earlier in the day they
were the second show off on that um and
i can't remember if it was a friday or
saturday
but you know they just had a lot of
sound issues and it took them a good 20
30 minutes half of their set was was
fixing the sound um so you're being kind
yeah yeah he came out and did a sound
check for 30 minutes is what they did
yeah it was it was completely horrible
but with all that being said she's
having a real moment i mean she's got a
book on the number one uh new york times
bestseller list she's done saturday live
uh the the the album has blown up uh
she's having a real real moment right
now and they think that she is a legit
star and she i mean i think that she is
and right you know it's just a matter of
time before this band becomes you know
you know becomes really really yeah i
mean i they think it's gonna be the next
florence and machine we'll see
but i i like him so much i really don't
think that there was a better song a few
years ago than roadhead uh
and even this last album is great i just
still can't stop listening to roadhead
um so i would go just for that uh but if
they're up against robert plant and
allison krauss that's a that's a tough
scheduling conflict i would still choose
japanese breakfast
all right so after japanese breakfast
robert plant you guys got anything
what's friday night look like
well we ain't even we're still in the
middle of the evening war on drugs and
arlo parks oh god i love an arlo park
oh god and bleachers all right so look
if there's anything anything that you
listen to if you listen to nothing i say
so be it
go see
arlo parks
i am obsessed with her absolutely
obsessed she's got this great sultry
voice everything is just so sexy
um i am a major major fan and um
i i can't i can't i can't talk higher
about her i'm in love with her yeah
so
pop over there to this tent and then
that leads into the chicks
yeah which yeah gotta see how could you
i have no problem with the chick show
none whatsoever and i know it was a fire
brand when uh when this lineup was being
rumored about and you know i think that
got squashed when they found out that it
wasn't going to be the headliner top
line
so i mean
nobody i think i don't think that there
is necessarily a problem anymore i think
the fact that they are where they are in
the lineup it makes people a little bit
uh feel a bit better about it but i i
think that that's a can't miss show i
think that's one of those shows that's
so going to be specifically great for
bonnaroo um they're they live in
nashville there's there's a good chance
sorry there's a good chance that they
bring out some friends um that could be
the show of the weekend
i agree
yeah well yeah i agree i plan to be
there
and that leads into
i guess what lord huron
maybe maybe go back to camp and regroup
i i hear you i have zero interest in
seeing lord huron i feel like there's
one of those there's so many late night
you know there's so many late night
shows to get ready for i guess right
yeah
pretty stacked as well
yeah king gizzard goose millennium
disclosure
you know i mean i i would almost
ask you why you're not gonna pop in and
see still woozy right after the checks
uh no okay i like still woozy um
he was uh he was on my radar before he
got signed to uh to
republic records it was a republic or
interscope that he signed to either way
the night that he got signed i was at
dinner with the a r guy at lollapalooza
and they could not have been more
excited about getting stew woozzy and
you know
then the pandemic happens and his career
gets this kind of like pause
i got a lot of faith and still woozy i
love everything that i've heard of him
um give him a shot just give him a shot
there in the last 15 20 minutes of his
set it's it's not a uh
i don't have a i don't know any i don't
know enough to say so okay
and then i would probably take a break
but at some point i got you gotta take a
break because uh you can't miss king
no and that's a long day already i mean
we started 11 drinking you know at the
beer fest it's a long day i i almost
think that the
the
conflict of king gizzard and disclosure
may be the biggest one for me
that's gotta suck uh i i mean because
king gizzard is that that's that's the
one of the day um
that would be what i
put my entire day around is getting to
that show and staying the entire way and
then trying to make it to 3 a.m for
goose
yeah
is that the one uh
uh taco was it king gizmo yes they
extended it by like 15 minutes
oh really which
just an hour and now it's like hour and
fifteen
which still seems like still long long
enough still not long enough yep
uh
by the way so that's a long good that's
a long pretty pretty loose till three
a.m again this is exactly why i say
don't go hard on thursday
don't go out on thursday you've got to
make it to 3 a.m because that that goose
set is gonna be fan [ __ ] yes yes yeah
it's going to be terrific all right
so somewhere in there you've got to get
you got to get a crate nappy don't carry
you got to get a crane happy
you got to get cleaned up if you can get
a shower you just got to eat something
get some energy some pedialytes some
water
you gotta really and then you're waking
up saturday and doing some uh urban
cowboy line dancing
yeah because this is just friday there's
still two more days we're only halfway
through that way so
yep well i mean if you count sunday as a
full day
if you count that and if you don't count
tuesday and wednesday good point great
point all right uh saturday you wake up
saturday you're feeling a little groggy
legs are starting to get tired back is
starting to hurt this is where you get
on the yoga wheel this is when you start
stretching out the back you do you know
some sun salutations maybe do a little
bit of yoga get that back back in line
have a big big bloody mary when you wake
up maybe two maybe three uh and then
what are you doing uh around about
midday when you walk in and get a spicy
pie what are you doing after
that go ahead i really don't have
anything until six saturday
um nothing planned really yeah i was i
was gonna say brad i know what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna walk in there and i'm gonna
turn right around and walk back really
see like i almost always do because i'm
gonna be this is where i would almost go
hard
first part of the day
and then just pack it in the rest of the
day because
i
love that kid patrick drony we talked
about him a couple of years ago
that's the one uh backseat lovers i
think is a great great rock band
um and then
femi cootie i
i why why would you not see femi um and
then after that i would pretty much i'd
i'd lock the day down and spend the rest
of the day at camp or hanging out you
know with friends because
i've seen churches so many times jude
and the lion i just that's how many more
times do i need to see them
i have no interest in
you skipped right over
you skipped right over maybe the
the one don't miss for me which is why
super jam
the super jam oh yeah and then this but
but the super oh that's right because
the super jam's early
it's really really why is the super
saiyan set
yeah why is this super jam sedan early
yeah it's weird yeah we don't know
and am i am i not correct
that all-time lows keep showing up on
all kinds of suggestions it shouldn't be
i'm like
okay oh
i i i just thought that was those that i
keep hearing from people yeah um i mean
i
that's super i have a problem with that
band because i'm so tired of hearing
monsters uh they're they're a fine band
um they had they had a big me too
problem um that seems to have i don't
know maybe it's [ __ ] maybe it's not
nobody really knows but they are
fighting it really really hard and
they've hired their own legal team etc
but the thing is if you're a radio guy
in this form at least the format that i
am we have heard monsters maybe 8 000
times
it this song has driven us nuts because
it will not go away
so
um
that i would i i am not going i would
never go to that show just because i
cannot listen to that song one more time
in my life without losing well you're
not going so there you go um and then
and then but probably super jam is the
one sort of like you know
uh we will have um
you know
russ and i are trying to set up work
interviews sort of things so hopefully
we can get some of that set for saturday
during the day and get caught up yeah
and honesty man yeah this it really
starts with yeah honestly
and and we haven't even talked about
going out into the plan
you know other than well see this is
what i was going to say you know
you always put super jam on the on the
list of things that you want to do but
it never ends up being something you
stay at so i can imagine spending 30
minutes at the super gym going back to
camp and just sort of packing it in
until mark ribollay
sure yeah um
i do want to stop at the who stage
before super jam and see charlotte sands
really
okay
interesting why why she's got blue hair
oh my god
you're bringing charlotte sands back to
the bus
i hope that she's old enough for your
advances how old is this poor girl uh
can i please
check before
how old is charlotte stands because i'm
very worried about this
i can't argue with this logic
i i just i don't see
i don't i don't see
a bio
charlotte sands birthday
are you okay she's 25. okay thank god
she's 25. so
charlotte sands let me introduce you to
my friend russ
who is a
he has a bus and an affinity for blue
hair
and an affinity for blue hair performer
it is really bizarre how you and brian
stone go after the same women
[Laughter]
yeah i might be fighting brian stone
over this
[Laughter]
all right hey going to charlotte's dance
all right uh and i i i do want to see
churches because i saw them at shakiness
and i want to see that show again it's a
great show it is a great show
yeah yeah yeah see i haven't seen them
like you so i can go from super jam to
that um
jude and the lion i've not seen billy
strings like people love billy strings
it's not something that i've i've really
figured out just yet
yeah you like it
very very talented and it uh it blends a
lot of things so it i'm gonna guess it's
gonna be a great show
yeah so you know depending on what else
happens that day and uh i guess you know
barry i don't know if you're going but i
will definitely be at that tool so
yeah
yeah be there um
and like you said the ribula you gotta
you gotta save up for that and you got
flumes so let me let me stop you for a
second so you are all in on going to the
tools show taco yes you're in i'm in
barry you're in
you're gonna do the whole hour and a
half the whole two hours probably oh no
i didn't say that didn't say that okay
i'm going that's that's like i said
depending on how that day and the day
before goes can i ask you
somebody can correct me if i'm wrong
because maybe i'm i'm
recently biased here but have you ever
seen a saturday headliner
have somebody play at the same time
usually the saturday headliner gets
the entire run of the festival and and
the freedom of only being being the only
artist playing at that time tulle
has 30 minutes of being the sole
band playing at bonnaroo
i would put it the other way in in my
memory of the history there were always
multiples except for the rare occasions
where they shut it down like for
mccartney and i mean that's my memory i
i'd have to go back i mean i feel like
there's always been something happening
but it's always towards the end of the
set
not 30 minutes into the set
am i wrong about that i mean fair and i
i like no well it's like i said i i you
know mccartney they did it and and uh
the whole reason why kanye's the kanye
fight started because he wanted nobody
else playing
well and but what i remember is being
surprised
that they did it that way because it
didn't give you any other choices you
kind of had to go see whoever it was
so i mean we're remembering it two
different ways i guess is what i'm
saying
um
i'm gonna have to go i have to go back
and look at schedules from the past
because something tells me like i just
there's something in me that says it's
just not often where saturday's
headliner
has
accomplished what they're doing though
too though
it's all on the what the other stage
i think they've committed to those fans
they're just gonna go that's a great
point that is a really solid point
right yeah i think that's what i'm
looking at yeah i mean i think that's
that's a very solid point probably not
going to pull a lot of those people no
matter who it is you know unless it's a
dolly or a mccartney or somebody like
that um
let me look
go back to friday and is
is the friday headliner on what
totally
uh
j cole no j cole's got conflicts too
um interesting yeah yeah you know
you're exactly right disclosure is there
on the other i mean there's not a spot
where
the other is not
completely represented so
yeah i mean that's a that's a good call
very good call
i think they just committed to that
stage and that that uh
audience especially losing the calliope
stage i just said it right i've been
over this and we've been over this so
many times
literally the guy who started the
festival told you what the word was and
you will not believe him
well calliope's not part of bonnaroo
it's yeah that's walter productions
isn't it
it is calliope the guy who started the
festival told you the word is galliop he
didn't start calliope
oh god
[Music]
um and so later on in the night uh
you're doing you're doing flume you're
doing mark um are you doing pigeon
playing ping pong how late is your night
going on saturday
it's a game day decision i i mean if if
uh
i'd like to be there for all those if
things are sure if they go right yeah i
don't have them dad's gonna need a dad's
gonna need a golf cart by then
i'm gonna totally be honest with you
taco you might be wheeling him around
um
saturday saturday night that was about
when barry's back started giving him a
lot of trouble a couple years ago the
hip yeah
and it's like uh
i could just i could see the pain but
you must
this is what i love about barry corder
he muscled through every single bit of
it and
he's so
unlike me
didn't [ __ ] once
didn't complain once i've never
i've never been so happy to be
embarrassed and shamed as the old man in
the middle of that field at 2 a.m when
when one of our friends got me a check i
mean that's right tara grabbed your
chair
but yeah chair went and stole a chair
but i would have i would have been
fighting and telling people i would have
been fighting and saying why haven't you
gotten me a chair yet no barry
complained nothing barry didn't have the
first
[ __ ] or complaint or
he just he refused i i knew the group i
was in
i don't know who i was with
you're saying that we would have
we'll be back
yeah we'll be back to pick you up man to
pick you up
see you in 2023.
yeah
see y'all anything else go on saturday
night that you want to uh you want to
get to
okay all right and then
honestly
i kind of think and i know this is going
to sound uh ironic coming out of my
mouth but i feel like this is how sunday
should be at bonnaroo
light
and easy
and not asking me to do a lot
i'll see what i see if i don't
whatever maybe i'll leave early maybe i
stay the whole night
i'll i'll see how my day goes
yeah exactly yeah it's gonna be again a
game day wake up and see what i mean
i'd like to see herbie hancock
a lot i'd like to see stevie nicks
but
that's yeah that's a lot if the heat is
hitting it's a long day
right and if if it's gone the week is
gone i mean i want to see all them
witches i do too
i'm surprised they put them on so early
that they feel like more of a
evening
set
they're 3 15 on sunday
nathaniel ratliff i definitely you have
to see that show you have to see that
show
i'll tell you one of my
one of my favorite shows i've ever been
to music midtown it started raining
nathaniel raytliff was singing in the
rain um
i i just was one of the man more magical
shows i've ever been to god he is just
so
good he's infectious i uh i saw him at
tippatinas in new orleans and i'm
talking a small spot i there's not a
show i will ever miss if nathaniel right
live is near me
and i think it's a a perfect
in you know we talk about it on this
show a lot perfect but right in the
field that's right that sound feels
exactly like bonnaroo is supposed to
feel and so you know we haven't talked
about this and we do it every year my
favorite time of my entire year is
when we get to the top of the mountain
driving from chattanooga we get to the
top of the mountain and we start to come
down and we see over into the valley and
the sun is pouring through the trees and
you get down to the base and just open
farmland and that's when
that feeling just hits me and rushes
over me and it's legitimately the
biggest it's the best drug that i can
take ever
keep your pcp keep your molly that's the
best drug that i can take it's it's
literally it courses through my veins
and it lasts me entire entirely until i
get checked in at the holiday inn and
then when we get onto the farm
i get that rush again whenever the right
band at the right moment when the sun's
going down
and the sound of the farm cuts right
through the noise and
you just nailed it barry and and i
haven't found that on this schedule
until nathaniel rate lift
yeah
yeah and in that moment yeah we've
talked about that many times you that's
when you can start picking up bonnaroo
right they're not doing that anymore um
every
well they're not doing the the holiday
inn either so i'm not even sure we'll
take that route but but for 16 years
that literally topping that mountain and
heading down
is like going into it's a different
world you leave you leave work and
everything alice in wonderland you're in
you're in a house in wonderland yeah
it's awesome yeah i'm trying to think of
like i mean i'm look
i'm looking at these
japanese breakfasts might have that
saddest sort of sound but it's on the
tent and that's not necessarily what i'm
looking for
um
tovlo is not it isaiah rashad's not it
was on saturday saturday no
all-time low is definitely not it
um yeah you just don't you don't have it
maybe churches churches might be the
first spot where i start seeing getting
that feeling but man it is all the way
until sunday where that
that sort of yeah there's not the my
morning jacket or the warren haynes's or
the
even the avett brothers or and it may
not be a sound that you like right it
may not even be a sound that you you
would gravitate towards but it is
legitimately the sound of that farm that
is the thing that the like the pulse of
that farm is through that kind of sound
and um it's what it was built on what
about taco where where are you going on
sunday
sunday uh going to see a pucifer i'm
gonna do go do another maynard band is
that the first time
this is i'm sorry the first first show
for you on sunday
uh before well all them witches but
that's earlier that's right yeah that's
right uh post first at 6 30 on the witch
stage and then yeah i do want to see
herbie hancock
yeah i think that you have to
yeah i mean i think i like that if
you're gonna be there
why would you
not
yeah yeah yeah you gotta see these guys
man these i'm telling you one of the
great one of the things i'm so happy is
i i saw solomon burke at bonnaroo before
he died
he literally died the next year
i s you know
charles bradley one of the i mean when
charles bradley comes out of the
off of the stage
in the first real tour of his career and
he's on the main stage of bonnaroo and
he's crying he's so happy he's been
waiting 40 years for this moment he
comes out to the crowd and he starts
hugging literally everyone that's there
and then he dies five years later you
don't know when you're going to be able
to see these guys again that's right
take the change john crying yeah john
that's a great example john prine the
photo on my screensaver is that i took
of john bryan the smile on his face
don't lose these opportunities i didn't
i didn't see the top
about that too i mean there's there's a
ton of those i know uh elvis costello
there with um oh who's the guy from new
orleans brad uh is elvis costello dead
oh they
the other guy the guy that he performed
with is and it'll come to me as soon as
we stop talking but uh
i mean how many times am i going to get
to see all this guys kill i'd kill to
see i was going to sell it back on the
farm i mean i've missed the other time
that he came i was like oh i was i was
such a loser kid like oh elvis costa
hello lame why did i do that what was i
thinking
i have no idea so that i could go see
life house i don't know what it was but
you know why would i why would i choose
anything other than elvis costello
bonnaroo i was an idiot i was a total
idiot i blew it yeah well we all have
them i mean uh
i didn't see um
lionel richie because i got an attitude
and it's still on everybody's you know
list and top shows and then with that
same with that same thought you got to
see stevie i mean just if you're going
to be there of course again
you could have left early by now and and
nobody would probably argue with you
about that but if you're going to be
there you might as well be there and see
stevie now
i will be totally honest with you i'm
really worried about that show
in the optics this thing's going to be
live streamed and if the crowd estimates
the way that we think it's going to be
oh i just i don't like the way that that
looks
yeah i don't disagree
i don't disagree but you know
if i'm there i'm going to absolutely for
sure yeah yep i've never seen her um
all right and there you go anything else
taco you missed anything on sunday are
you really only doing two shows really
sunday oh and probably stevie nixon
hancock yeah four yeah but ten
well he he he's been well yeah he's
already had charlotte sands coming back
to camp nut butter and uh
his weekend is locked up yeah he's
blocked out
[Laughter]
sorry stevie
you gotta spend some time during the
early saturday
getting ready yeah he's got company
getting ready
my company's coming ridiculous
yeah he'll be barry you've gotta you
gotta you went from dashboard moms to
dashboard children
[Laughter]
all right that's you know what when you
when you lay it out like that it is a
it's a full slate you know and and yeah
you
when you look at it the way that i look
at it it
of course it comes across as negative
and empty but when you lay it out like
i'm going and here's what my schedule is
going to be
you do have a pretty packed you know day
and a half there two days
yep i'm sorry i just was trying to find
the name
yeah
it's the artist i was trying to think
yeah i was there with with elvis
costello
so yeah no it friday is good
friday is terrific friday is uh going to
be
you know mind and body numbing uh but
there's plenty else to do sat
i think thursday's better than i thought
well yeah i mean it changes a little bit
with
but you know by the way um i will say
now that we've gone through this i'm
kind of irritated well first off i
cannot believe you're not going to the
urban line dancing at any point uh why
in the world would you not spend half an
hour with urban cowboy line dancing
um
i would be all into that
but what what really bothers me is that
i i don't think that there's a single
new orleans connection
at all in any of this any of these days
and i know that sounds a little
homerish because
i love new orleans so much but this this
festival was sort of
built by the combination of new orleans
and nashville and the fact that there's
literally nothing that is
new orleans-ish on this
lineup is
kind of depressing to be honest idea
yeah there's not even a sneak in jakes
anymore is there
joe god really
barry is that true
well no last year they painted it white
and it was going to be the house oh the
house of matrimony that's right oh no
well
along those lines i haven't even
mentioned in
the the plazas i mean at some point
we're gonna have to we're
going to go out there and just see
what's going on so
um
[Music]
you know if we if somebody's listening
and we haven't mentioned any of those
things
sorry it's partly because it's not on
the schedule that we were looking at but
partly because
you know that's sort of a game day kind
of thing we'll have to figure well i
mean
get out there it's a great point because
you know there will be a
secret show out there somehow with
somebody somebody's gonna pop out there
just like cage did a few years ago um
and just like you know there was going
to be that
possibility of the foo fighters um
there's gonna be somebody out there and
i
you know what if you give me a second
i will look through the schedule and
give you an idea as to who i think it
might be
um
santa rate lifts a very good possibility
you know that's just a big band to start
taking out there yeah
uh
but i mean the ruham guys have an event
on friday they do they're having emo
night which you know could could be some
good dashboard bombs there
yeah
um
there is a there is a quote-unquote
secret show at the beer exchange uh i
don't know if you guys know about that
um
oh you know i mean i wouldn't put it
past i wouldn't put it past jack
antonoff and going out to a plaza late
friday night and doing
something that'd be cool too
so we don't even know i mean it you know
it's very possible you we wander out
there and just stay out there you know
yeah
if somebody's got a cachet
yeah i'll follow you anywhere i may
never see taco
taco's going to sleep on a i guess
[Laughter]
yeah or you know maybe in a darkroom
tent somewhere oh man i i could see jude
and the lion doing something late
saturday night in a in a
in a uh in a plaza i could see loop
daddy finding something to do on friday
night i mean yeah you're right there's
there's very good possibilities of
something popping up uh throughout the
festival out there um i was trying to i
was looking for
have they not put out the map yet taco
no
well
there is a map they put out in like
january yeah but that was the map
from years ago no i saw one last night
yeah
you did it's not a current map yep
yeah i know that barry but that was the
map that came out
two years ago for the canceled bonnaroo
what i'm wondering is if they put out a
map and
uh if taco's right there's no
snake injection coming soon if you
if you go to the uh map in the app
okay there's no map yet yeah so and yeah
i'm pretty sure
um snake and jakes is done that would be
really sad because not only is snake if
that's the case not only snake and
jake's done but also uh our guy from
crawfish king
uh shaggy who always does the crawfish
boil um
is now he would like bonnaroo said we
don't we don't really want you to come i
don't know well maybe they didn't say
that but he was not he was not invited
back to bonnaroo uh
so
i mean that is damn near every new
orleans connection that was originally
the way that this this whole thing was
founded
gone that's a little sad for me
maybe it comes back let's pray that it
comes back somebody listen you need your
new orleans connection you need your new
orleans thing you need prez hall you
need a second line you got to have
something that connects you from your
history to now um and it cannot just be
nashville singer songwriters
don't forget your roots that's exactly
right
if you want brad to come back
yeah that's their worry that's their
word mr new orleans
uh
i mean there's yeah i'm looking yeah
you're right there's
there's nothing
on here anywhere about
snake and jake's christmas barn and that
is just heartbreaking that's
heartbreaking because now that you've
been to the actual snake and jakes it
means so much more to you now
yeah i've been to both and um yeah i i
would love to go back to sneaking jigs
by the way barry you remember the the
great thing about snake and jake's in
new orleans
that's where we found out where taco was
not truly a pbr fan
the man likes mick ultra yeah i mean oh
it was it wasn't a cultural was it
no it was like it was high spoiler yeah
yeah
so
when you come to the bona roo beer
exchange even worse please bring him a
miller high life in exchange for a pvr
absolutely
you won't know the difference he won't
know the difference
by that point just i'm strong with that
blue hair you don't even see the can
blue you got blue hair you got blue
ribbons i mean new hair and high life
you will be married by the weekend you
will be married by sunday
oh lord
you'll have you'll have pbr cans hanging
off the back of the bus as you drive
away just married
[Laughter]
all right and then the other thing too
are we absolutely sure that you're going
to be
driving the jam tracks and
bringing people around
has that worked out because that
oh i don't know if we're driving i know
we're going to get on there and
hopefully talk to people we we we got to
please the driver please please ride the
jam tracks
yeah try but
i hope so and you're going to video
right taco you're going to have the
whole little camera thing
for sure yeah i'll be on camera all
right well i'm i'm super jealous i'm
going to be even more jealous next week
i know i was debbie downer last week but
you know when it actually happens i'm
gonna be really super bummed
i'm gonna be super bummed um yep so next
week we'll have like a bonnaroo
free-for-all and uh hopefully maybe
we'll get some calls and and do it live
and and have some people from camp nut
butter the always enthralling brian
stone may join us
um oh man god it's going to be just a
ray of sunshine like you'd never believe
yeah it's very exciting like a big warm
hug
big sweaty
pity hug yes
no touch it out
bro
get out of here all right uh good picks
good picks uh we'll list them here uh
here at the end taco put them up and
then um we'll talk to you uh next week
as uh the festival gets closer by now
actually you're probably listening to us
driving to the festival so uh enjoy
i hope you are just hours away you're
just hours away from the greatest
weekend of the year it's never not great
what podcast's up to
[Music]
consequence podcast network